the phil potts are at odds merging their
different design styles and before the
break cass and ted each gave opening
statements defending why their space
needs
to kind of speak to their needs and cass
wants a tranquil reading room and ted
wants a game room to entertain family
and friends well ted
um we wanted to bring in uh
reinforcements uh he has a surprise
witness to help him drive his case home
mikael yes ted go ahead and tell us who
our surprise witness is
i brought in the big gun i brought in
the woman who really makes the decisions
in the house and that's our 15 year old
daughter
[Applause]
it is el philpott come on out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh l i've been so excited to meet you
doing my research on you you are such a
good girl thank you thank you he's a
good girl oh my god i don't know if i
like this though it's not fair yeah it
does seem like you're siding with dad on
this one speak your truth ale living the
truth i'm sorry i'm sorry i love you but
i have to defend dad because i think we
need a game room so i can hang out with
my friends and you're always saying you
want me home more um okay ted uh that
was a pretty smooth move i mean god you
really brought down the gavel with i
want to win i think it's only fair that
i bring in a surprise witness
and i think who is your witness i'm
gonna bring in a professional oh none
other than interior designer
and co-host of queer eye bobby burke
oh you're playing
i'm really excited because also there is
another detail here you need to know ted
has this diver's helmet that is his
grandfather's um but i feel like you
really want to make it like a statement
piece and um just speaking as a woman
um
this i don't think i would want as a
centerpiece in design but the
sentimentality really speaks to me so
i'm curious as to what bobby has to say
about it let's roll the tape
hey drew and mikael it's bobby burke
here and i 100 object to the divine
helmet ted wants to add to this room you
know i love a piece that tells a story
but this is not the story that we want
to tell in this room the space should be
a sanctuary and not a reminder of
stressful stuff like battleships so
ladies and gentlemen of the jury i
implore you to side with cass on this
issue the helmet is not it
[Applause]
we need to throw that out that's
overruled i have to agree with bobby on
that one and he is a fantastic expert
[Music]
you